Hi, my name is Jason Richelson.
I'm the CEO of Shopkeep and we're here at One Girl Cookies...
...talking about Valentine's Day Tips.
Tip number one is start early.
Start running reports from your point of sales system to see what you sold last year...
...to make sure that this year you have just enough but not too much.
Also remember, Valentine's Day is on Friday this year...
...so you have a full week of sales, so be prepared.
Tip number two is be original.
Try and sell new and different products so that you can be selling on value...
...instead of competing on price.
That's how you can set yourself apart from the competition.
Tip number three is also to start early with your customers.
Use that all-important e-mail list, your Twitter feed and your Facebook page...
...to make sure you're letting customers know what kind of products...
...you're gonna have for Valentine's Day...
...so that they're prepared and know what to come look for.
Tip number four is to offer a really great in-store experience.
You should have sections set up for him or her...
...so that customers can quickly find what they need.
Tip number five is to work with your neighbors.
Work with some stores on your street or in your neighborhood to help bundle products.
Maybe you sell some of their products in your store...
...and they sell some of your products in their store.
It can make for an interesting changeup for Valentine's Day.